Democrats looking to unseat President
Trump are gearing up for the first
debate of the 2020 race this coming week
it will take place in Miami on Wednesday
and Thursday with room for just 10 of
the 24 major candidates each night most
are spending the weekend in the critical
early primary state of South Carolina
despite recent fighting within the party
about comments connected to that race
the to race rather the first event of
Fish Fry revealed a choice not to take
aim at each other
ed O'Keefe is in Columbia South Carolina
this morning ahead who looked like a lot
of fun Michelle there's no other state
where the black vote matters more early
in the process than here in South
Carolina
last night Vice President Biden mostly
avoided the heat stayed out of the fryer
as Democrats focused instead at that
fish fry on President Trump
let's not flounder let's get out there
and kick some bass thousands waited in
South Carolina's capital on this
sweltering first day of summer to sample
4,400 fish sandwiches and more than 20
Democratic candidates some damn good
fish and we know that we've got hot fish
and cold beer two of the best things in
the world in matching t-shirts the
Democrats it's time for us to reclaim
our place in the American democracy that
we have here with bigger fish to fry
President Trump let us stand together
let us defeat Trump we can make up to
four years of damage he's done but eight
years of damage will be almost
impossible to get back in lightening
round like appearances that twenty other
Democrats avoided attacking the
front-runner we have to stay together
and elect a Democrat even as the South
Carolina Democratic kingmaker behind
this event Congressman Jim Clyburn
earlier on CBS n urged Biden to explain
comments he made this week about past
work with segregationist senators it
would be helpful to everybody what's
wrong with explaining what you meant New
York senator Kirsten Gillibrand told us
Biden needs to go further Joe Biden is
he the best reflection of the Democratic
Party
is the nominee well I'm running for
president because I think I have the
best vision for America any of the stuff
he's facing though disqualifying for
someone who wants to run for president
some of its concerning and I just don't
think it should be so hard to apologize
but the former vice president picked up
support from a Civil Rights icon I don't
think the remarks were offensive back at
the fish fry has seen about his biblical
as it gets on the campaign trail loaves
and fishes served two thousands at the
fryer April maziq whose family has
served up the fish for almost all of the
events 27 years we didn't know better
the secret batter in a secret batter
still she offered us a taste moment of
truth that's some good fish now this
coming week there'll be two debates down
in Miami there are so many candidates
they've got to do it over two nights ten
candidates on each night Jeff it's gonna
be a busy week for Democratic
presidential candidate all right thank
you very much and glad you got to have
some fish there appreciate it Keith